the credits are rolled and the reviews
are in but is Indy's final Adventure
whip cracking fun what does it belong in
the museum Indiana Jones and the dial of
Destiny has got a lot riding on it it's
the first film in the Indiana Jones
franchise since Kingdom of the Crystal
Skull which the tourists who received a
frosty reception from fans when it came
out in 2008 style of Destiny is also
unique in that it's the first film in
the franchise to be neither directed by
Steven Spielberg nor have a story by
George Lucas top all of that's off with
a reported 300 million dollar budget and
is clear that the pressure is high for
Disney's first and maybe only Indiana
Jones project of course a significant
number of fans will be happy just to see
Harrison Ford suits up as Indie one last
time but Nostalgia only goes so far the
film is a June 30th release date in the
United States but as it premiered at the
Cannes Film Festival reviews have
already begun trickling in so what do
critics have to say so far about Indy's
final Adventure it's probably worth
considering dial of Destiny in the
context of the franchise's impressive
Legacy
[Music]
Raiders of the Lost Ark is widely
considered one of the best adventure
films of all time and people have plenty
of love for Temple of Doom in the Last
Crusade too
dad
your experience for me
happens to me all the time well it's
hard to say whether dial of Destiny will
reach those Heights it certainly appears
as though critics think the movie is a
step up from Kingdom of the Crystal
Skull more importantly many critics
found it to be a fitting conclusion to
the Indiana Jones film Saga fans can
rest easy knowing the fifth installment
of the Indiana Jones franchise offers a
fun old-fashioned romp games Radar's
critic enjoyed the throwback Vibe of the
movie writing there's a nostalgic
old-fashioned feel to the film a Roller
King globetrotting ride that pits Force
Intrepid Adventurer against the Nazis
once more certainly a Meg sub for 2008's
outlandish Kingdom of the Crystal Skull
with a more grounded Story the final
verdict from the outlet is 4 out of 5
stars with the summary a terrific Thrill
Ride with Ford and fine form Indy's Last
Stand is a highly satisfying blend of
action humor and emotion others agree
the film is a lot of fun with one mild
criticism being that it plays it too
safe the radio time says perhaps the
film could have been more daring it
feels fairly safe but fans will leave
Cinemas feeling like their old hero had
one final great outing in him while most
of the focus is naturally on Harrison
Ford the movie boasts a talented
Supporting Cast including Phoebe Waller
bridge and it sounds like she's more
than a match for Indy himself as the
guardian notes Phoebe Waller Bridge is a
tremendous co-star turn as indie's
roguish goddaughter Helena Shaw who
wears shorts and shirts making her look
like a grown-up naughty Enid Blyton
heroine meanwhile the radio times pray
to tell the film grapples with an aging
protagonist the review reads at its
heart has a great performance from Ford
one of his most emotional outings as
Indie as he comes to terms with his
aging body and life regrets Games Radar
also knows how in these struggles with
his age and regrets grounds the movie
the review says we see the character who
has grown older but not necessarily
wiser drinking a bit too much he's full
of regrets about pursuing fortune and
glory and leaving his loved ones behind
not every critic has been so enamored
with the movie however Donald Clarke of
the Irish Times was a bit more critical
giving the film 3 out of 5 stars and
concluding that nobody with a brain in
their heads will compare dial of Destiny
favorably to the first three films but
even if it's no radius of the Lost Ark
it sounds like the dial of Destiny will
see Indiana Jones go out swinging at
this point even a solid Indie Adventure
might be all anyone can hope for